Michael crews what can we learn about
Donald Trump from reading the art of the
deal we can learn a lot I think and we
should when you're studying Donald Trump
and I think everybody at this point in
this country should be studying Donald
Trump the art of the deal is the
foundational document and at this point
it reads sort of in retrospect like a
campaign playbook
first and foremost I think what we can
learn from the art of the deal is that
he is selling fantasy and he's doing
that using hyperbole those are his words
not mine
well in fact his words from the art of
the deal are a plate of people's
fantasies people may not always think
big themselves but they can still get
very excited by those who do that's why
a little hyperbole never hurts people
want to believe that something is the
biggest and the greatest and the most
spectacular
I call it truthful hyperbole Monica
Langley that I think that's exactly what
he's doing and he's he's not ashamed to
say that's what he does do you know what
I mean it's worked for him his whole
life
I did write an article for The Wall
Street Journal and asked him if this was
his playbook hiding in plain sight and
he first was a little taken aback and
then he said well you know it is
automatic and it comes naturally to me
so I guess you're right and then he said
running for office at running for
president the first office he's ever saw
it is like the biggest deal in my life
and so I called this the campaign by
negotiation and you've seen that all the
way through and right now as he's trying
to get the GOP elite and the GOP donors
to come to aside it's just a series of
more negotiations so he does a little
bullying he does a little cozying up and
sweet-talking all the things that are
elements of the deal in this book so I
mean this comes naturally to him it
worked to get him to this point to be
the GOP nominee we will see if it works
against Hillary Clinton in the general
election Carlos Lazaro when you read the
art of the deal last summer
what was your reaction my reaction was
he's the deal right it's not his
buildings it's not his TV shows
he's the pitch it's all about the aura
which is a word that recurs in the book
the aura he presents whether he's
dealing with politicians whether he's
dealing with developers construction
crews he's his own deal it's it's it's
it's really in this book this book as as
Michael said is really sort of the
foundational document that if it were
books of the Bible this is Genesis right
this is this is the beginning is the the
beginning of Trump and and it was the
first time I'd read it I had never and I
read it because of that clip because he
said he we need a leader who can write
the art of the deal so I figured well we
have to he sold me on that it has he
been consistent since he wrote this book
in nineteen since it was published in
1987 consistent in his in his books in
his behavior in his bromides I think
there's a that's your work I think
there's a lot of him that we're seeing
today that you can see in this book he
says for instance sometimes you have to
denigrate your opponent's to to succeed
to to win to get ahead and we've seen
that in in the campaign whether it's
it's the the other Republicans running
in the primary or whether it's members
of the press and so I think I think he
has been far more consistent than
inconsistent in terms of living up to
what he says in the book he was 41 when
it came out I think you kind of are who
you are at that age and I think that's
that's who he was
Michael Cruz you know he's also says a
pace to be a little wild and so there
are there are lines in this book now
watching the last year of this campaign
that just jump out at you you're
watching him be what he said he was in
this book the context of when this book
comes out is I think pretty interesting
I mean this isn't just a a handbook way
to understand and were to try to
understand them it's it's in a very
particular point in the broader scope of
his life Trump Tower opened in 1983 it
was his both sort of his opening salvo
and his crowning achievement it made him
a big deal in New York City and you can
talk to this more than I can probably
made him a big deal in New York City
this is what made him a big deal beyond
New York City and such a big deal that
the following year he started making a
series of deals that sort of put him in
a tight spot and hugely over-leveraged
he bought the Eastern Airlines shuttle
and renamed the Trump shuttle he bought
the Plaza Hotel
he bought a third casino in Atlantic
City there was so much confidence coming
out of the art of the deal and this
success of their two deal how much it
sold that I think we can learn as much
from the art of the deal as we can learn
a lot from the air the deal we can also
learn a lot from what happened in the
year following the art of the deal what
he did with that confidence and some
would say even overconfidence they not
to get away from I'm sorry not to get
away from part of the deal but his
second book is called surviving at the
top and it covers that period a little
more end of all his books it's the only
one that sort of vaguely introspective
that he he admits that things aren't so
easy in his business dealings in his in
his in his personal life you know he had
he and and Ivana had had separated and
then of so it was to me that was
interesting of the books then we writes
the third one out of the comeback he
says in the introduction like don't pay
attention to surviving at the top my
heart wasn't in that book you know he's
he's back he's back and he wants you to
forget that he ever wrote that you know
he says you know art of the deal and and
this third one this is really you know
this is what you need to know you know
forget this other bonus three books
taken as a taken together are I think
surprisingly revealing and in large part
because of surviving at the top it comes
out at the end of 1990 it's called
surviving at the top and here's a man
who wrote a book called surviving at the
top when he was neither at the top or
surviving barely surviving yeah but
what's in there what since arriving in
the top is some of the most
introspective stuff he's ever said or
written
he's sort of honorable yes which is not
something he he likes to be and and it's
not something he shows hardly at all
but the art of the deal is it's sort of
the beginning of that of that of the
trilogy the Trump trilogy initial Trump
religious you know when he's out at
rallies and I've gone to many with him
and traveled on his plane and Bennett is
his office in Trump Tower and the the
person is at the rallies is very
bombastic all the bravado that everybody
sees day to day when he's in his office
or even in his penthouse met Melania
that kind of thing on the plane he is
more thoughtful and he's more composed
and when he's talking to other people
and when I've spoken with him and when
you see video and he he answers like a
normal human being which a lot of people
think he just can't be that he's not
that person but he can't be that person
however to get him to be introspective
what you say I'm did not read the second
book to get him to be introspective is a
little more difficult and I have tried
do you know to do that and I think he's
just kind of beyond that I mean he
doesn't look back he's always looking
forward you know where am I gonna go and
one of the one of his statements in the
art of the deal is you know I think big
and I push and I push and I push until I
get there and that's what he's doing
right now well let's read that quote
Monica Langley I like thinking big I
always have to me it's very simple if
you're going to be thinking anyway you
might as well think big most people
think small because most people are
afraid of success afraid of making
decisions afraid of winning and that
gives people like me a great advantage
mm-hmm
and one of the first times that I met
his daughter Ivanka
who is a star on the campaign trail
everyone thinks pretty much that his
three adult children Don jr. Ivanka and
Eric you know they are pretty good kids
do you know adult children and they're
running the Trump Organization in his
place right now and the first time I met
Ivanka she said this quote to me if
you're gonna be and before I read the
book
my father never called that my father
always taught me if you're gonna be
thinking anyway you might as well think
big and I thought really that's what he
told you as a little girl and then it's
in this book you know and then I talked
to Eric the other son and he said oh
yeah we this is really how he grew up
and Don jr. said I was go up in the
office these this is what I heard we
knew this book because he didn't take us
out to play he took us in the office to
play and we had to listen to this day in
and day out and then the campaign staff
you know lives hope Hicks his
communications director she's read this
three times Corey Lewandowski is
campaign manager before he went to his
first meeting he read this book so
everybody is reading it then switch over
to the campaign trail and when you say
people are afraid of success he even
though he's so successful I would go to
a rally with him right on the plane get
out of the plane they dubbed Trump Force
One because it's gonna be you know it's
better than air force you know then then
Obama's playing because it has the 24
gold karat fixtures etc so we'd get out
in the first people I would see have
been in line all day long are a lot of
blue-collar workers and so I would go up
to them and I said why are you so crazy
about Donald Trump I just got off this
you know gold-plated leather plane they
leather seated plane they said he
understands us and playing to the
fantasy he is going to make us better he
knows we need to be successful and we
have a chance with him so he's playing
to the fantasies and they think I'm not
gonna be a billionaire but maybe I could
make $100,000 this year it's just worth
pointing out that somebody else drew
read the art of the deal was Mark
Burnett who had done survivor and then
wanted to put Trump into a survivor type
reality show which of course turned into
The Apprentice which my opinion turned
into this campaign I mean without the
apprentice he would not have been able
to run nearly so successfully for
president maybe you disagree
nobody became a household name
everybody at these rallies almost -
without any exception had seen The
Apprentice beyond even just having
become a household name he was on that
show portrayed as what he wanted to be
seen as which was the ultimate boss and
so you can trace back even The
Apprentice to the art of the deal if not
for Mark Burnett having read this book
when he was sort of down his luck out in
California trying to make it in TV and
then thinking about the art of the deal
when he's trying to come up with sort of
his next survivor there's a there is a
line between the art of the deal and the
apprentice and the skin and the right
right in the book though he you know he
you think you're gonna pick this up and
learn all these you know they've been to
the great wisdom of deal-making
and you know the the jams I mean they're
they're fairly banal I mean like it's
like you know think big and I think but
then at other moments he almost
contradicts himself and he says look he
can't get too greedy you go for homerun
with every pitch you're gonna strike out
a lot so sometimes I settled for triples
doubles and even the rare single yeah
you know and so he and and in other
after the the trilogy of the of the
memoirs he wrote a lot of business
advice books and even in those it's like
you know pursue your dreams unless
they're just never gonna happen you know
it's like that kind of that's the kind
of advice for for deal makings so it's
it's understandable it's it's not always
actionable Carlos lazada he writes in
the art of the deal it irritates me that
critics who've neither designed or built
anything themselves are given carte
blanche to express their views in the
pages of major publications whereas the
targets of criticism are almost never
offered space to respond he's managed to
carve out space to respond in through
social media and in many different ways
at the same time that he's so dismissive
of critics and he's focusing on
architecture critics in in the book he
cultivates them essentially he he's very
cognizant of the the power of the press
he was obsessed with the architecture
critics of the New York Times at the
time of this book
and so you know this campaign has seen a
lot of tension between Trump and and the
press but this notion of you know him
hating the press is to me is is sort of
overblown and and kind of a myth I mean
he he's very smart about cultivating the
press and he's very clear about that
in in this book he says look you know
you'd rather be written about nicely but
the worst thing is to be ignored you
know even even bad stories are good for
business do you both agree with that yet
so there's a through line in this book
and throughout sort of his the Trump
literature over the last three decades
but in this book it pops up over and
over again he does not he has a belief
that there is no such thing as bad
publicity
there is no such thing as bad press he
would rather get good press over bad
press but bad press works to all
attention is good attention and to this
point and not just in this campaign last
thirty years of his public life he has
not been wrong really it in 1990 in
early 1990 the business pages are
reporting on his looming financial
catastrophe the tabloids are reporting
on the breakup of his marriage and his
infidelity and it diminished him a
little bit but he emerged somehow
stronger because of the attention his
ability to leverage attention of any
kind into an even larger public persona
and so fast forward to the last year all
of these things that should have killed
him have not only not killed him they've
amplified this as aura this persona of
Donald Trump now the candidate I think
in the art of the deal a lot of it the
all the chapters after 1 & 2 are going
through different transactions or things
that he has accomplished to me the first
one is a day in the life and the second
one to me it was called trump cards
elements of a deal
and that's the one that I went through
point by point with him and I found even
though elements of the deal the trump
cards were about specific elements that
he practices I found that they were
splendidly in this campaign and to
follow up on you the one that get the
word out he was like be outrageous be
controversial and you will get attention
so the temporary ban on Muslims the
illegal immigrants from Mexico faithful
hyperbole well but they were
controversial I mean even attacking
Senator McCain as you know not worthy of
being a war hero every time he said that
people say he's dead in the water no the
next week he got another 5,000 people at
these rallies that were attracting
twenty and thirty thousand people do you
know what I mean so he would do that
that's one get the word out and the
other thing that he did in getting the
word out he mastered the use of Twitter
now it has come back to bite him a few
times more recently but he was the first
of the candidates to really I think
exploit Twitter and we've seen Hillary
in recent weeks Hillary Clinton trying
to use Twitter herself
you know so we'll see if she's going to
try to answer him on that I think his
use of Twitter is just a the latest sort
of social media version of what he's
been doing exactly his entire life I
mean when before page six of the New
York Post in the mid 70s you use the New
York Times society pages and then page
six sort of ushered in a tabloid era and
then tabloid and trashy TV comes in in
the 90s and the internet and and now
social media wherever he needs to be
however he needs to exploit the media or
the press he has he has done that very
very Abele I think this is a little bit
far field from the art of the deal but I
think what we're gonna see here is is
whether whether he's reached a point
where this level of scrutiny and the
level of seriousness is so high that
this still works and his his as I said
his abiding belief that all publicity is
good publicity not so sure it's gonna
play out that way over the next however
many months between now and November 8th
then again a lot of us have been wrong a
lot of times along the way when was that
that was at the
in February in Virginia in southern
Virginia and I sat down with him before
he went out to a rally we were in like a
little library and the interesting thing
is I gave him the book and I highlighted
I had your version I think I handed him
and so I gave it to him and I could see
out of the corner of my eye his staff
was like what the heck is she doing like
and afterwards they told me if we had
handed him a book he would say what what
the heck you can't don't give me
something to read but he did read it and
he agreed with it do you know what I
mean and he still is very much like that
which is why I wanted him to fess up
that he's still very much that way
because I've been observing it about him
and we all know he's so loosey goosey
out there and he likes to see and go
with the flow and he became a master of
that out on the campaign trail sometimes
to his detriment most of the time to his
benefit when he would read the crowd do
you know one react to the crowd I mean
he was always doing that seeing what
they were doing and one of the things
one of the elements of the deal in his
book is know your market and the market
that he knew better than any other
Republican candidate was this market was
angry it was anti-establishment it was
tired of being believed around the world
and at home of being weak and he knew
that market and he struck that chord
there's a lot of insight into his
management style that which which you're
bringing up that is evident in the art
of the deal you know he he brags about
how you can just get to him directly
right that looking a lot of big
businesses there's all these to get an
answer you have to go through seven
layers of executives we're all probably
unnecessary anyway you know the Trump
Organization it's always Trump
Organization Center the Trump
corporation rights from organization you
can you can come to me you get an answer
immediately you know the the flipside of
that is is is that it's micromanaging
right but he the the sort of
loosey-goosey way the campaign has been
run you know here he says look I don't
like a lot of number crunchers a lot of
eggheads a lot of you know fancy market
surveys you know I go from the guy
mm-hmm right and committees and
consultants
no no committees and consultants and so
it's it's all him he'll listen to people
to a point it's ultimately his decision
maybe that's how it should be it is the
Trump Organization but I think if we're
fast forwarding to next January when he
moves into the West Wing not sure how
well that that open door will work and
that is a phrase that that comes up
often only the last few decades and you
heard him say it's not gonna change that
much if he were to become president and
sometimes you need an open door but
sometimes you need a closed door the
Oval Office otherwise it they're just
too much stuff coming at you I think is
going to be the problem
and his business as sort of sprawling as
it is and has become it's it's something
he does some extent has been able to
corral and hit with his capabilities and
you know I think the Oval Office is
going to be a little bit different than
the 26th floor of Trump town but he has
run the campaign that way you know just
the way he has run the Trump
Organization he makes his own decisions
if I were on the plane with him I would
ten minutes when they said we're gonna
land the pilot says we're about to land
that's when everybody buckled back up he
would write down six words over the
points he wants to make he had never had
a speech he never had a briefing book
nothing he would come up with six words
one time I got my iPhone and just copied
it and a ten and I mean I said I'm gonna
copy it
a copy didn't I attached it to one of my
stories he did it that way and remember
his campaign manager that took him
almost to the end until he hired Paul
Manafort at the end to be sure that he
got rid of Ted Cruz his campaign manager
the slogan in his office on his white
board was let Trump be Trump and that's
what he did and that's what Trump wanted
well as three working reporters longtime
reporters
y'all are familiar with the White House
and the management of the White House
and the press management and here's our
message of the day here's our message
tomorrow etc it's
how much attention to that do you pay
does Trump pay no do you pay as a
working reporter I mean I'm looking at
the management his loosey-goosey
so-called loosey-goosey style versus
managing a candidate managing a
president it's something I've actually
been thinking about and working on a
little bit of late and you know the
president is the president there is no
question who's in charge of the West
Wing of the White House at the same time
there is such a volume that is coming at
you and such a volume of important
hugely consequential things to sort of
play it so loosey-goosey to go
seat-of-the-pants as he has done in many
cases for many years is I think
dangerous and for previous presidents
who've been more inclined for that side
of the spectrum it hasn't worked well
and they've had to adjust I'm thinking
maybe a Bill Clinton here who came in
and preferred an open door and sort of
loosey-goosey in his own way and had as
a chief of staff somebody he brought
from home essentially and at some point
needed to say okay I'm the president and
this is this is serious business and I
need to make some adjustments and did
and I think should he be president I
think that's something that that all of
us should be watching for see how this
management style which has worked to
some extent with mixed results for 30
years in Trump Tower how that would
translate or would not translate to the
Oval Office I think how it's worked in
the campaign too is it's gonna be hard I
think for him to say look I mean this is
working right you people are been
expecting him to maybe make a pivot
right after the primary to the general
there's no I mean he's only pivoting
he's leaning into the same direction
right the I think that it's gonna be a
few times yes
there's many hard to persuade him
continue I think it will continue when
he gives the so-called policy speeches a
little bit I mean I was in his office a
month ago right before he was about to
use it and it was
in the conference room and he was
practicing okay so he's trying to like
think that way his people were the new
people he'd brought in wanted him to
practice a time or two and he's done it
what maybe three times or something
Carlos was that I'm sorry we interrupted
you no no that's all right I mean the I
think it's gonna be hard to persuade him
and hard for him to to think that he
needs to change right because look no
one thought in you when he came into the
race he was like ninth in the polls
right now you know it seemed like this
kind of sideshow and and he won he you
know he beat the the the field that was
supposed to be you know the of the most
depth than the most serious and you know
Republican field in in a long time and
so you know not only have we not seen a
pivot I just don't know who's gonna
persuade him that he needs to change
until he's actually there and so I don't
know I think that's gonna be that's
gonna be a hard sell he talks in the
other deal about listening to his own
advisers and his sort of small
collection of executive vice presidents
but also how he talks to cab drivers and
workers in the street just people that
he runs into and gets sort of a critical
mass of voices that then allow him to
make sort of a gut that's how he makes
decision now I don't think a president
Trump would walk outside on a
Pennsylvania Avenue and start talking to
people and then make a decision it just
won't it just can't work there are
there's a bureaucracy Congress does all
these things that that a president needs
to sort of navigate in a much more
complicated way than anything he's he's
he's done I mean one of the things this
comes out and I say seven as I said it's
four years after Trump Tower came out
Trump Tower is is a is a is a shining
example of Trump's management style
opening it up he that the project
manager was a 30-something woman at the
time I make an interesting collection of
people
made Trump Tower work you see less of
that I think as as Trump goes on he sort
of transitions from a guy who builds
things he built Trump Tower from the
ground up to instead a guy who puts his
name on things and it is clearly a
genius-level marketer and licensure but
maybe a less disciplined manager that's
I think the trend line of his 30-plus
years as a as as the character he's
created as Donald Trump but you know he
in his business and perhaps if you were
to become president but it's been true
in his campaign he does go outside the
box in his hires and he does not bring
in the consultants the standard people I
mean the person who is his social media
guru has he expands all his Twitter his
facebook to gazillions of people he
started as Trump's golf caddy okay his
his press secretary she was a Ralph
Lauren model that then Ivanka brought in
to work on her line and to do other
things their marketing for that line and
now she's the press secretary and I
think most people think she's been a
fairly honest broker through all the
tumult of this campaign and for then I
find out from the grown children that
the guy who runs the Las Vegas hotel was
used to drive them to school so I mean
he does think outside the box and
because he used to grow up on
construction sites and dealt with I mean
he he had to work at the construction
sites Eric and Don Jr told me that they
had to work at construction sites since
they were 11 or 12 years old so he does
look at people in other things and isn't
afraid to put them in the mix so I don't
know if he can do that at a presidential
level but he has done some of that
traditionally through output high
expectations on people who are
by-the-book under-qualified totally and
then if those people succeed that's
great it looks great and if they don't
yeah bye-bye yeah and they're beholding
you're fired
holding
he rises loyalty one thing he says in
this book is that he prizes loyalty over
integrity even loyalty is the most
important thing well just why spit by
Corey Lewandowski and also why he is so
loyal to family there's nobody he's more
loyal to most of the time than family
his brother Robert at least as we see
him in the art of the deal is is a key
component and now his is three first
children that he and Ivana made are
people who are extremely important in
his in the Trump Organization I have a
very simple rule mr. Trump rights when
it comes to management hire the best
people from your competitors pay them
more than they were earning and give
them bonuses and incentives based on
their performance that's how you build a
first-class operation he goes on to say
in my life there are two things I found
I'm very good at overcoming obstacles
and motivating good people to do their
best work one of the challenges ahead is
how to use those skills as successfully
in the service of others as I've done up
to now on my own behalf hmm
so there is the Trump Organization in
sort of the broadest strokes and then
there are other subsidiaries some very
large like Atlantic City and I don't
know that he overcame obstacles super
well in Atlantic City I mean he writes
and the art of the deal it's I love
casinos I love the glamour I love the
cash flow it's very good business being
the house yes yes it should be and it
almost always is for almost everybody
except it wasn't for Trump kind of it
was kind of good for Trump individually
but for people who work for him for
Atlantic City overall for investors and
shareholders it was decidedly less good
over the course of time for corporate
bankruptcies so before we sort of talk
about the management gems that are in
the art of the deal and I think there
needs to be some sort of corrective and
again this was written
ninety-seven you know he had not
experienced really failure at that point
it starts happening in late eighties and
into the early 90s and then there are
portions of his business record that
have been the opposite of success over
the course of time
Carlos was odd up he writes in here I
fight when I feel I'm getting screwed
even if it's costly and difficult and
highly risky it there seems to be a
sense of right and wrong in this book
that quote plus the fact that he writes
about helping that woman who was losing
her family farm and he held a fundraiser
for her he said she worked hard all in
life and here she is losing her farm
it's just not fair and so what does he
do right he describes that that's in the
first chapter of art of the deal he
calls the bank right and says he wants
to like pay off her mortgage into
something and they say look it's too
late you know she's mean who knows how
this conversation really transpired but
that's how he's describing and so what
does he do he does what Trump does he
threatens a lawsuit he's like I'm going
to you know slap a huge lawsuit on you
for murder because you drove this poor
woman's you know husband to suicide and
that you know he talks about he can't
believe it's getting so much attention
this thing he did of course he's putting
in the first chapter of the book as well
but he you know he immediately lashes
out with his most of his standard weapon
which is the lawsuit in that first
chapter he both threatens a lawsuit and
is being deposed and another one just in
describing his week you know that's
that's that's how it goes so that that
combativeness that was that we're seeing
in the campaign and that litigiousness
and the the threats of litigation we're
seeing it are very evident here he has
handled critics if you want to call them
that over the course of the last year in
this campaign the playbook for that is
in the art of the deal I mean that is
one of the things that with all of his
sort of inconsistencies that is not
that is a that is an absolute
consistency if somebody does something
that he doesn't like if somebody says
something or write something that he
doesn't like he goes after them or the
Trump University litigation I mean he is
hammered hammered hammered on that to a
fault
he would say you know yeah if he had
settled this before settle does I know
that he doesn't settle this and so you
know the question I think is pending as
we move into sort of the summer and the
thick of the general election whether
that was the right move in this in this
situation if he had settled we wouldn't
be talking about this or we wouldn't be
talking about it nearly as much and he's
just he can't accept that he might have
been wrong in this case and so it is
full assault on the judge and and and on
down anybody who is critical of how of
Trump University and how he handled that
entire episode when he admits mistakes
in this book it's always in his failure
to see how stupid other people were you
know that kind of thing or I never
realized that you know he was um he was
an owner in the the short-lived USFL
right the the the alternative pro
Football League and his biggest mistake
he says is he didn't realize how weak
the other owners were you know those are
the kind of mistakes to which he is able
to admit he chalks up the loss in court
in the NFL versus USFL antitrust suit to
the fact that the jurors almost took
pity on the underdog NFL I mean it's
just it's just laughs about looking back
when most objective observers would say
that if there is one person who ruined
the chances of the USFL to be a
secondary professional football league
in this country and has Donald Trump he
is the reason the USFL didn't work it
might not have worked the NFL is just an
absolute behemoth and has become even
more of a behemoth since then but Donald
Trump is the reason that the USFL didn't
work when it didn't work the way it
didn't work so when you all read the art
of the
did you find it to be accurate did you
find his descriptions of deals to be
accurate selectively truthful
he's as I think a lot of people are you
selectively truthful I found it totally
in character with the person that I've
come to know I didn't know him back then
but I found it totally in character with
his you know truthful exaggeration he
calls it he loves to be the best show
the show that he's the best all of that
and I will say because I write about
CEOs and billionaires for the Wall
Street Journal and I think all of the
CEOs and billionaires that I cover have
some of Donald Trump and Donald Trump
has some of them they all occupy a rare
rarefied air they all are full of
themselves to be to that point they have
had to knock away competitors they have
had to think differently and so one
reason when I first met him in August
when everyone else thought he was like
crazy and had no chance and I went in
his office and introduced myself and he
knew who I was because he had read some
of my profiles of others and so we got
along and I said look I'm gonna treat
you
legitimately because you're a CEO and
billionaire and so from that point on I
knew that I could work on a level
playing field with him in a way
differently because I kind of knew the
ground he walked and it is a little
different I mean he is much more maybe
as much more ego much more you know a
little craziness but they're all I think
all CEOs and billionaires to some extent
have these tendencies when you when you
look at a book like this I mean it
should be fact checked assiduously and
people shouldn't should look at that but
I mean I think like a lot of books
certainly I mean this is he was not he
was politically attuned and engaged in
the book another politician when he
wrote this but I think also with just a
lot of political memoirs and a lot of
books like this of you know of major
public figures they're they're probably
right they're not they're not meant to
be a very detailed honest accounting of
a life or a career you know so and I
would I wouldn't I wouldn't limit that
to out of the DL limited it really is
sort of any any kind of especially
campaign time political books um they
usually not very good and they tell very
selective truths as you as you put it
this one is actually it's entertaining
like I mean I'd rather read this than
read you know whatever Tim Pawlenty
campaign memoir was you know like this
is this is interesting earlier in the
primaries when I was reading a lot of
these sorts of books I enjoyed the art
of the deal relative to some of the
other books by some of the other
candidates which are just dreadful at
least this one is fairly entertaining
did you all pick up in this book why
it's the Trump Organization and not
Trump Inc or anything else organizations
started when it was Donald Trump I think
that that is a key thing that he it's
just himself but he needs to to be the
Trump Organization to start very early
business deals when he had nothing to
sell yes Sarah
Trump organization is all about the aura
I think I assumed it was some kind of
like business formality some reason why
you call it one thing or another well
it's different marketing it was it was
Morgan is a father a sugar or score per
inch yes people that people can see he
says people consider you to be sort of
more worth dealing with I think that to
my point about this being selectively
truthful what he doesn't right at that
point in this book is that a huge part
of his ability to talk with these people
to start making some of his earliest
deals in the 70s is his father and his
father's political connections and his
father's business record if he were just
Donald Trump and Fred Trump had not been
Fred Trump and had not done what he had
done in Queens Brooklyn building all
those middle class homes no way Donald
Trump would have gotten the years of
some of the people he was able to talk
to to start some of those those early
deals but at the same time he he
distances himself from his father
quite
graphically in this book and for good
reason I mean this is a this is a we've
seen this in the in the in the campaign
I am a self-made man and this is not
just a campaign thing this has been
something he's sort of over protested in
my opinion throughout his public life
downplaying the role that his father had
specifically politically and financially
with especially his early success he
could not have started doing some of the
work he did on the Grand Hyatt and even
into sort of early portions of the
putting together of the parcels for
Trump Tower I think it would have been
much much harder without his father's
influence and and his father's
exceptionally important including with
money and and so it's not in his best
interest and he is a he's not
necessarily a self-made man when he is
is a is a self created character and so
I think that those two things sometimes
get conflated and in the the publicity
of Donald Trump my father had done very
well for himself but he didn't believe
in giving his children huge trust funds
when I graduated from college I had a
net worth of perhaps two hundred
thousand dollars and most of it tied up
in buildings in Brooklyn and Queens is
that accurate
is that a full statement I haven't
researched that to know if that's true I
don't know if it was precisely two
hundred thousand dollars when he
graduated college but I think we should
pause and acknowledge that most people I
did not have two hundred thousand
dollars a net worth of two hundred
thousand dollars when I graduated
college that's a lot of money and we're
talking about the 1960s so you know to
say that as a defense that oh my father
had only so much to do with my success
my net worth tied up in buildings in
Brooklyn and Queens built by Fred C
Trump to say that as a defense for that
for his his sort of self-made persona is
sort of rich I think I think that the he
obviously learned a great amount from
his father you know from everything that
he did in in Queens but clearly he liked
Trump to
father but what he ultimately did but
clearly he learned a lot from his dad he
did get a great start from his dad no
matter what the amount is I'd I never
looked to find out what the amount is
but he did learn a lot and got some
amount sizes his closeness is sort of
personal you know he says you know my
father's the man who most influenced me
how much he learned from him so he you
know he doesn't want to sort of diss dad
in this in this kind of family sense but
he does want to create distance in a in
a business and and professional sense
and he wants you know he he in the book
and and on the campaign he's talked
about how you know my dad said never
going to Manhattan it's too tough you'll
never make it you know stick to Queens
in Brooklyn but I want it to be big you
know I wanted to so he he sort of
suggests like yeah my dad you know
taught me so much but even he didn't see
what was possible he didn't think big
but you know the book is dedicated to
his parents
you know Fred and Mary truck so it's not
to show Collective truth though there
was a ton of money to be made in the
middle of the 20th century using
government subsidies to build
middle-class homes Fred C Trump took
advantage of that
big time those things had dried up by
the time Donald came around so what
they're gonna do but go to Manhattan and
to take advantage of a very down economy
in the middle to late 70s which is
really what what launches him I mean
there's an aspect of of luck and of
timing in addition to any sort of skill
and make no mistake there are undeniable
skills in his in his skill set I mean he
has a full toolbox in terms of ability
to sort of promote and even especially
the earlier stages of his career ability
to build buildings understand sort of
what the public really wants not what
the public says they want but you know
here's a crazy factoid that he actually
can't I've been with him when he went
through the new Trump Hotel that's going
to be in the old post office here in
Washington DC that he's making into a
luxury hotel on Pennsylvania Avenue so I
was in it
with him and he likes awesome molding
and he's like that's crooked there why I
mean he did you follow up with a crooked
was he or was II sort of showing you how
hang on yeah but then you got the guy he
goes was that is that crooked and so
they took it out and said well not
really if you look at it like this and
you know the guy was obviously feeling
chastised and then he went through
another room and he said I don't really
like the way this turned out but it's
too late to change now and the manager
said yes it's too late to change now I
mean he did he does pay attention to
details and we know he goes through all
the things that go out on the campaign
which is one of his elements of the
deals contained the cost he ran his
campaigns you know the primary campaign
for 40 million dollars which is unheard
of Jeb Bush had a hundred and fifty
million dollars in super PAC or whatever
and we know he looked at every single
expenditure that went out of the
campaign so whether it's paying
attention to the details of construction
or the details to expenditures you know
that go out from his business or his
campaign he does do that now he can't
micromanage like that of the federal
government though his big argument to
the public is I'm a great businessman
read the art of the deal I will manage
the country like I manage business you
see that I know in the book you know one
of the early details is he talks about
how he had been you know he was in
charge of the of the decoration the
holiday decoration at Trump Tower you
know he's my just number reading like I
just I wrote in the margins like he does
that yeah you know like he also
explained why and it was because Trump
Tower had an aura it had a yes it had a
purpose and he wanted to make sure that
the Christmas decoration and that's how
people you know people who walk by who
go into the league that's that's that
that's what you see it is a man landmark
and crowds walk by it's right next to
Tiffany's I mean it is right I mean
Tiffany's is part of it it's it is a big
deal on everybody crepe so she's really
good at that
I mean he does get involved at that let
me know what you know or he's telling us
that he does he get involved at that
level mixture both in this book in other
books and in real life if you will
between I can't be bothered big picture
and like the smallest micromanaging like
the wreath typically typically in my
read and into my reporting he
micromanage is the most when it comes to
things that are very aesthetic and
that's what we saw with the that gold
wreath and I think in that part of this
book he says sometimes not often but
sometimes less is more
we're just going to go with one
beautiful did rarely know even you know
he tells us how he likes earth tones
more than primary colors or at the
office I can't remember one of the you
know he's he gets in that earth tones
yeah you know he's at that level of
detail now when he's talked about how
he'd manage when he's talked about who
he might pick for a vice president he he
said that he needs someone who really
kind of knows how to do stuff in
Washington because he sees himself more
Moors like the chairman of the board
right like the he sort of sees the
presidency as being the chairman of the
board rather than the CEO or chief
operating officer officer who's in there
you know in the nitty-gritty and getting
getting getting his hands dirty so I
think that's that's a fascinating
transformation or fascinating way to
sort of take the you know look vote for
me because I'm I'm a successful business
leader to see how that would work as as
president sometimes you can be a
chairman of the board sometimes you need
to make the call but then that's when he
says I know how to do deals you know I
can make deals with Congress the
question is when he's made deals it's
usually with another person who also
wants to get the job done and dealing
with Congress when there's so many
different people was so in the agendas
is going to be a horse of a different
color for this moment when he's talking
about how he doesn't like negotiating
with the Japanese and it's because they
always bring in a group of people it's
all
like eight or twelve people in the room
and sometimes you can convince two or
three people but it's hard to convince
12 people in a three-line because you
have to convince a lot of people
Congress has more than 12 people and and
to to suggest that you know I'm a great
deal maker because I'm great at the one
on one that may be true it is utterly
inapplicable to the job he would face as
as president but yeah you know just trot
them all in one by one that's what he'll
do
Monica Langley are you this was somebody
who has access to Donald Trump are you
worried about the crossing him and
getting kicked off the campaign trail
getting kicked off the list of access
well no I'm not if he decides to do that
I mean the tape that you showed was at
the same rally where the Secret Service
he was traveling with him choked did a
chokehold on the photographer for time
that was supposed to get back on the
plane with him to do the cover shot for
time and I actually because I had been
with him earlier we actually had good
access we weren't in the the pen with
all the reporters so we had video of it
and the campaign asked us for the video
so they could decide what kind of
statement to make because everybody was
like your campaign your Secret Service
it's not their job to put down the press
they that guy was not a threat and they
asked me for the video and I said you
can get it when it's on our website do
you know what I mean I mean there were
they were pissed off about that I mean
they get pissed off he didn't like he's
not like several things that I've said
and done you know or when I've called
when I was the one who got an exclusive
when he decided to quit self-funding the
campaign as he went in the general
election and all the staff were saying
he's still weighing the decision about
whether to you know go get race go fund
raising like all the other candidates
so I called him directly on his phone
and I said Donald are you gonna quit
self-funding and I could hear he was on
the speakerphone or not gonna hear
people saying well we're still deciding
it I said Donald I'm talking to you are
you gonna quit self-funding and I said
or are you gonna sell a building because
it's gonna cost a billion dollars
potentially and he goes well Monica
I'm gonna quit self-funding but I'm
gonna put a lot of money in it myself
and then I'm gonna help the RNC so you
know I just go directly I mean it wasn't
like he was ready to say that I wanted
to say that and I couldn't piss him off
you know but I knew I needed to get that
because that was the next stage and it
ran against his brand because you know a
big part of his brand during the
primaries all these other people are
sucking up to special interest and I'm
not so I wanted to get that and I knew
the staff had kept telling me stay away
stay away and I just called him directly
and asked now he could have said leave
me alone I'm not gonna talk about it
whatever so yes that always happens but
I still um my first responsibility is
the Wall Street Journal in our readers
not Donald Trump and he knows that I
think if he felt otherwise he would not
respect me and I think from the whole
time I mean if he thinks that you're a
week and he's gonna nickname you and
stuff like that I think your dad well
two quotes from the art of the deal and
for you Carlos lazada sometimes part of
making a deal is denigrating your
competition and I don't go out of my way
to be cordial to enemies I think he he
wrote it then and he's proven it during
the campaign whether it's it's certainly
not limited to the press you know it's
it's insults to his his primary
opponents its speaking I think
denigrating is a pretty good word for or
what what we've seen lyin Ted crooked
Hillary yeah low energy jab that never
he never got rid of that from the August
when he started with that little Marco
you know he I mean some of them are he
talked about art I mean he does manage
to
capture something with some of these
sort of very juvenile
you know nicknames or kind of these
throwaway lines like he'll say you know
it's always a mess with Hillary and
people are like yeah you know there's
always a lot going on all right you know
it and it's you know he's I was
wondering what what the Donald Trump
put-down nickname would be for Donald
Trump I don't know but the he's very
good at that he's very good at that and
you you remember and he just repeats it
incessantly like Low Energy was this
thing from the very beginning from like
day one when he was way down in the
polls he's talking about Jeb he can't be
President you know that very low-energy
you know which is this kind of veiled
insult you know it is it's this you know
it's this kind of like macho thing you
know like it's but he's he's he's
talented at that and and he's certainly
done it with the press he's done it you
know overtly with with with with megyn
kelly but we also well he what's his
current relationship with the Washington
Post yeah I said well he has severed the
relationship with the one women post in
the sense that he he's revoking
Washington Post access to his events now
that doesn't mean that we can't cover
him we're going to continue to cover him
aggressively our executive editor who by
the way has gone toe-to-toe with the
Catholic Church in the NSA so I'm
feeling pretty good about this
our executive Marty Baron issued a short
direct statement saying this is a
repudiation of a Freeman in independent
press but we're gonna continue covering
him aggressively honorably fairly like
we've done you know throughout the
campaign and we're not the first could
you have predicted him doing that given
some of the Washington Post coverage by
reading the art of the deal he he really
cultivates the press and he talks about
how he cultivates the press in in the
art of the deal and you know how he's
bragging about crowd size all the time
now and the art of the deal he brags
about how many quarters come to his
press events you know we had 50
reporters we had 200 reporters local and
national so I always from this book I
might have guessed that he would find
ways
to to cultivate particular journalists
and news organizations rather than just
shut them off and we're certainly not
not the first Politico has experienced
this as well so I wouldn't be I it it's
not surprising because of how
aggressively he goes after enemies but
it is it is slightly surprising in the
sense that he he seems to have a very
symbiotic relationship with the press
and and cutting it off hasn't been a
strategy that he's really employed in
the past
Michael Cruz so in the art of the deal
he writes that he doesn't take critics
too seriously unless and until those
critics get in the way of his objectives
and right now I think you're seeing that
with with the press and not just with
the post Politico York Times USA Today
has done some really good investigative
work of life lots of places have there
has enemies now they are critics and
there they are literally in the way of
him becoming president because there are
months more the amount of resources that
have been put it onto the Donald Trump
beat it's unprecedented I mean what has
changed is the context in which the man
and the story sit he for a generation
has been famous
he's been famous for a long time he's
never been important maybe you disagree
he's never been good distinct Horton
mmm-hmm now he's very important he is
hugely consequential he is a man of
global importance and so because of that
I think he is being covered in a way
that he has never ever ever been covered
not even close and it's starting to make
him uncomfortable but because I think he
judges accurately that this is
problematic that if the coverage
continues this way which it will it will
eventually put him in a position of
weakness which is a position he hates
heading into November one doesn't need
the press
as much as he did I mean there was no
Twitter in 1987 right there was no way
to directly address the crowds that you
wanted round-the-clock cable either I
mean now he can dominate cable and they
were you know they're not yeah I mean
and yeah then he can call into any show
or appear when they want cable is
desperate to have him on and now Hillary
Clinton is trying to play that game you
know in the last week every time he goes
on she goes on same thing she's starting
to call in she's going is she's going on
to Twitter you know when he says
something bad about her she responded
recently delete your account or delete
this account
it was the most read tweet by her ever
when she responded directly to him so
you know we'll see if she can go
toe-to-toe with him and if it's the
right thing for her to do from the art
of the deal one thing I've learned about
the press is that they're always hungry
for a good story and the more
sensational the better it's in the
nature of their job and I understand
that the point is that if you are a
little different or a little outrageous
or if you do things that are bold or
controversial the press is going to
write about you 1987 so this question
that we've been trying discussing we in
the media and beyond really for months
at this point did we - that's excited
there is a we mmm did we create Donald
Trump know if we're talking about Donald
Trump the presumptive Republican nominee
Republican primary voters created Donald
Trump Republican lawmakers who endorsed
him created Donald Trump the media did
not create Donald Trump but if we're
gonna talk about the media's role the
press's role in the creation of the
candidate the successful candidate that
Donald Trump has been kanata that
conversation cannot start in June of
2015 it has to start in 1976
I mean honestly we can talk about
Twitter and how he's used that very
effectively we can talk about how often
he is sort of unbroke has unbroken
speeches on CNN Fox MSNBC all those
places
before cable and before Twitter it was
People magazine it was page six in the
New York Post his Playboy it was Playboy
he's always identified a way to have a
certain omnipresence in a different kind
of media and in a less serious media and
I think what has happened over the last
25 30 years is that there is less of a
distinction between oh well that's page
six and this is the business pages in
the New York Times
people used to sort of draw that
distinction and there were kind of two
separate Donald Trump's there was
celebrity Donald Trump on page six and
in People magazine and then there were
lifestyles of the rich and famous
and then there was Atlantic City Donald
Trump Trump Tower Donald Trump being
covered in the inside of the New York
Times what's happened now I think is
that it's just it's all just stuff it's
all just content and so he has used that
reality to create confusion or people
are already confused and he's taken
advantage of that contrary go ahead and
say he was one of the first rich and
famous to be featured on laptops which
premise he may have been on the first
show it was you know like that's he's
been famous
he's as a business leader and I think I
read this in your paper he's been famous
longer than Bill Gates right he's been
famous London I mean I think of any sort
of living business leader you know his
his run of Fame has extended as long or
longer than then than any of them and
it's not just been in business it's it's
the whole Trump persona so you're right
I think that's that's a smart way to to
look at the you know did the media
create Trump trope and it's if it if
that's the case it goes back far far
longer okay I remember as a young kid in
the Midwest learning about Donald Trump
through an ice rink it's something he
comes back to again and again in the art
of the deal did that make his national
reputation well know the story yeah well
I I had a daughter I mean my daughter
was born in New York City and I've lived
there for many years
in Tennessee from Tennessee areas like
but Wollman Rink is a perfect example
for him to show success because it was a
nightmare it never worked and then he
took it over and made it a success in
months not years and it was my
daughter's favorite place to go as a
toddler and child so it shows government
gridlock what she's fighting today
it shows he's a can-do person on low
dollars I had a head of schedule
so it is it is a classic Trump success
and no wonder it's tiny but no wonder he
brings it up all the time brings it up
in the air the deal he brings it up in
just about every book he writes and my
daughter who's now 17 will say it was
her favorite place in Central Park to
visit okay it is a it is a simple story
with a simple storyline it was yes a
success but it is it is so small
potatoes compared to some of the other
things that Trump has done and many of
the things so many other people have
done and so it is it is this very
straightforward tale of the success of
private enterprise over the incompetence
of the public sector and he has milked
Wollman Rink since 1986 for all that
it's worth and then some I think we can
all agree always when I when I would see
him talking about that story it's it's
in so many of the books you're right I
would remember like when Mitt Romney
would talk about the Olympics you know
and it's like yeah that was a big deal
you know and this yeah well nothing the
Olympics you know is it was a bigger
deal than than fixing a skating rink but
but after a while is like is that you
know that can't you can't hang so much
on that that doesn't prove to me that
you'd be you know terrific at all these
other things and there's a larger record
but it's you know people love the
Olympics you know people love ice
skating rinks you know kids like it's
it's it's so it's like this morality
tale you know cuz he hated the mayor and
you know he showed him up and so yeah he
loves he loves writing about it
he also writes in the art of the deal
about televisions city
what is television city television city
well what it would have been was is a
plot of land on the Upper West Side you
can certainly speak to this he had
options on it not once but twice
and sort of never really did even close
to what he wanted to do initially it's
one of the first plots of land he had in
the 70s he was trying to get NBC to stay
in Manhattan which of course it did
ultimately anyway but trying to get it
to move from midtown out to his
gargantuan new sort of Trump branded
city within a city never really amounted
to the variety of plans that he that he
laid out over the course of decades
really mm-hmm
there's this threat like I mean if the
way talks about trade deals and stuff
like you know they're eating our lunch
they're gonna go to New Jersey they're
gonna go to New Jersey you know and
that's that's what he kept but he kept
saying you know if he didn't get what he
wanted
then you know New York was gonna you
know would cease to be the media capital
of the world which has not last I
checked you know occurred in the second
grade Donald Trump writes I actually
gave a teacher and black eye I punched
my music teacher because I didn't think
he knew anything about music and I
almost got expelled as he ever talked as
he talked about this story since well
hyperbole this this was as I understand
it not a thing that actually occurred
was he it was he a difficult child
absolutely he also discusses something
that other people have confirmed his
brother building a tower out of blocks
when they were boys Donald and Robert
and then using Roberts blocks as well
and gluing them together so that all of
the blocks would be Donald's blocks in
the form of a building admits what seems
to be the reality that he was a
difficult confrontational child to then
of course as a teenager was sent upstate
to a military academy by his by his
father but I'm not sure we've ever been
able to
ferm the punching his second-grade
teacher in the face story be great yet
to find a second great music teacher
would what's interesting is you know
that's a story that he he says look I'm
not proud of it but he's proud of it
right because you know in the in the
subsequent sentence he says look this
just shows you that from very early age
you know I wasn't afraid to to you know
voice my opinions and tell it like it is
and it just reminds me of the the
controversy over Ben Carson's memoirs
and you know did he or did he not stab
someone or try to stab someone a big
deal out of that which Trump made a huge
deal out of saying how like how it
couldn't be true how it just you know it
wasn't well right and if it was true
what kind of a sick person you know
brags about this and so it's just odd
that you know you're in the situation
where things that you do as a kid but
you wouldn't really be proud of become
these these points of pride because they
show that you know you're unconventional
that you you tell it like it is and you
know and you're not afraid to voice your
opinions it's memorable it's a memorable
detail whether it's whether it's
entirely accurate
this is 1987 a lot of superlatives in
this book kind of like listening to a
Donald Trump speech I mean he uses a lot
of superlatives also you know losers
right the world's losers are the people
who are jealous of you right he's like
the only back you know drawback to to
fame and to success is that you get you
get all the people who are jealous and
envious of your success I call them the
world's losers right it's a lot of the
same rhetoric it hasn't it hasn't
changed all that much so it has been
there has been consistency he gets into
it more later and later in the Trump
literature this becomes more of a more
of a theme this idea that the world is a
zero-sum place for me to be a winner the
other guy must necessarily be a loser
but you can certainly see the the
groundwork for that worldview in the art
of the deal and certainly he's taken
that into the campaign you know from me
to win systematically almost
chronologically these other people have
to lose I'm going to target Jeb and he's
going to he's
to be a loser and then you know ben
Carson and Marco Rubio and and on and on
you know for me to win you must lose
there's a there's much more of a sense
of competition than there is of any
emblems of collaboration I think in the
art of the deal you can tell he's an
avid competitor and he does use the word
loser in the art of the deal and for
example when Carson suddenly rose up to
be like almost number one with him were
surpassed him for a week he decided on
his plane I'm taking him down today
tonight okay that's when he went on
stage and talked about the belt you know
how could Carson as a child what she
said in his autobiography have stabbed
someone and the belt buckle stopped it
from actually penetrating the other
child and you know cuz Carson never
revealed who it was so he said that just
couldn't happen it was the first night
that Trump had Secret Service Trump said
somebody come the stage come up here
with a knife or somebody have a knife I
want you to try to stab my belt buckle
and it won't prevent it it'll flip over
and the knife would go in my stomach and
the Secret Service is like down there
like this and you know but he said I'm
and then he said so either he's lying
about it or he had these tendencies and
he's like a psychotic murder you know he
has these tendencies that should make
him incompetent to be president but he
would just as you said Michael he would
come with I'm taking this person down
next any time anybody got too close to
him I'm taking him down I think the
difference between the primaries and
what we will see over the next coming
months is that it is a one-on-one
situation now whereas before in the
primaries sort of a collection of people
splitting up support easier targets I
think then than Hillary Clinton Monica
Langley you say you call Donald Trump on
his phone in his office or on his
personal phone are you still able to do
that given how close we are to the
conventions given how close we are to
the general election yeah can still get
through
I think his schedule is much more
precise now than at the beginning
and most reporters really didn't care to
get get close to him and I was doing a
profile of him early on but if I need to
I think I could still get him I mean
when I call him I say I wanted I saw him
recently when he was in Washington last
week speaking at the faith forum or
whatever and that's when I toured the
old post office building that's becoming
a Trump luxury hotel so I still try to
keep in touch I'm not one of the
reporters who are embedded with him we
have other teams The Wall Street Journal
has other reporters who cover him on a
daily basis I usually do you know page
one future stories so I don't try to
follow him every day I just try to jump
in occasionally but you know I mean he
we have tried to do tough stories as
well we did a story about easy really
worth what he says and when you look
through all his financials you know and
did a big piece that was said this is
what his income really is and he
actually couldn't self fund if he even
wanted to do you know all the way
through and we've done stories about how
he did not pay all his bills or kept
extracting concessions from people that
he didn't want to pay full amounts for
so I mean we are and will continue to do
that so I do agree with you that the
press is now going to get much more
vigilant about what has been his
practice not just what he says but what
he does
also I think this war on the press as
worrisome as it is is a no pun intended
a bit trumped-up I think it's a little
phony because as we've discussed here
there is this incredibly long-term
symbiotic relationship between the press
and Trump and I think in the case of
Politico in the case of the post he's
going to wreak redentor all these places
if for no other reason the story has to
turn a little bit I mean he if to the
except that he's thinking about this as
an ongoing narrative which I think he
does at some point you're going to say
okay okay come on back in as if he's
some sort of benevolent monarch
if you were Hillary Clinton would you
read this book oh yeah absolutely
absolutely I think or I'd get someone to
read it and tell me what's in it I don't
know if she has time but yes I think so
I think I think it reveals a lot about
him and in the same way it more and more
so than any sort of subsequent books I
think do and it's the same with Hillary
Clinton actually the best book to read
about her is still it takes a village
it's the one that most clearly not her
memoirs you know if this is the one that
most clearly lays out her political
vision when she cited the other night
when she became the presumptive
Democratic nominee
she said it still takes a village you
know so just the way he keeps citing the
art of the deal she keeps citing it
takes a village do you know they both
cling to their original books do you
know so I do think that people who want
to know kind of the hearts of these two
candidates they're gonna be pickin in
November could read their original works
and find out a lot about them Michael
Cruz I think people should read not just
Hillary Clinton and her staff but people
all people should remit the art of the
deal every voter should be the art of
the deal and then to the extent that
they have time keep reading
you know and do it chronologically and
not just the books he's written but the
books that have been written about him
there are I'd say six very good very
worthwhile biographies or if you don't
have time or the inclination to read
entire books there are oodles of really
good incisive profiles on Donald Trump
you know starting with Wayne Barrett's
work in the Village Voice in the 1979
Murray Brenner in 1980 in New York
magazine and in Vanity Fair in 1990 up
until somebody like McKay Coppins for
BuzzFeed and in 2014 it's not that Trump
is not known it's all of this is known
he's been he's been a public figure and
people have been reporting on him and
not just since fluffy celebrity ways at
all
for decades put it into Google start
reading it is sort of the way I see it
it is your home
work as an engaged citizen in between
now and November 8 and I can tell you
going to a lot of these rallies I mean
you know one of the elements of the deal
in chapter 2 is the last element of the
deal is have fun and when I have seen
Donald Trump have fun is in the rope
line I mean he does have fun up at the
rally getting all these people excited
he goes in the rope line and sometimes
he spends 30 minutes in the rope line
where people stand and and talk to him
his favorite people to talk to are the
people holding the art of the deal and
there are so many people that say please
sign my book he signs every darn book
that is out there more than a hat that
he makes money on more than a sign is
the art of the deal and he's proud to
say it's probably the number one
best-selling look out there business
book out there is that true it's not no
I think the Tampa Bay Times did uh did a
whole look at this and found that it was
maybe the fifth or sixth which is still
pretty good that's selling business book
how to make friends and influence people
until Carnegie is still by multiples the
the the best-selling business book but I
like what you're saying about fun you
know I think I suspect this is the most
fun he is going to have in this process
and I think something he says in this
book I think it's an art of the deal and
it may be in one of the other two
trilogy books he he says that the what
he's really about is the chase you know
he says the the same assets that
excitement assets that excite me in the
chase often once they are acquired
leaving me bored for me the important
design wives the important thing is the
getting not to having you know and I
think that does he want to win
absolutely right he wants to rub it in
anyone's face he will write another
amazing campaign book I'm sure what
we'll learn all about that but I just
the the notion of having to run this
thing day to day as president I his
probably a lot less exciting to him than
winning it a couple of months ago Glen
thrush a colleague of mine at Politico
interviewed Roger stone kind of a long
time
political consultants for Trump and
Glenn asked Roger stone does he want to
be President
and I thought it was really interesting
how Roger stone answered he wants to win
okay I never understood how Jimmy Carter
became president Donald Trump writes in
the art of the deal the answer is that
as poorly qualified as he was for the
job Jimmy Carter had the nerve the guts
the balls to ask for something
extraordinary that ability above all
helped him get elected president well
Donald Trump is exactly the same way
don't you think I mean it's all about
having the balls to do anything I mean
that's why I said if if any reporter
shows weakness to him I approached him
as an equal I think we all have to do
that
I mean I have seen Network anchors or
the correspondents come to say well wait
we want to ask you say spit it out or he
moves on I mean he really has no
tolerance for you know being nice if
you're not strong I mean he's just all
about the you know being confident
moving on and he he wants he comes from
a position of strength you have to show
strength and his children when they come
into the office they say we need to do
this this and this they don't say oh dad
what about this I've seen the kids come
in and say I need you to meet with
so-and-so about this deal
they're like telling this and this do
you know they're not saying well what
about this and what about that thing
about why he gained respect for Jimmy
Carter is customi Carter asked him for
money right he after his presidency I
think for the Carter library for the
courtesan or something you know he he
asked Donald for a donation and and
that's what impressed Trump right that
he would have the guts to ask for a
large amount of money at the bottom of
that page the page on when she tells
that Jimmy Carter story he also gets
into Ronald Reagan who of course at the
time of the publishing of this book was
that was the president and he says about
Ronald Reagan you know I think Americans
are starting to catch on that he's just
a smiling pretty face and there's not
much going on there I'm paraphrasing but
he is not kind to Ronald Reagan sitting
president in 1987 in the art of the deal
which should be pointed out in the
context of what he says about Jimmy
Carter as well right iran-contra you
know like this was not a great time in
the Reagan administration
in the subsequent books he gets religion
and he you know he talks about you know
what a you know how terrific Reagan was
but in his foundational document as you
put it he's he's not a fan he thinks
he's an empty suit the deal to it comes
out right before he right around the
same time he kind of talks about running
for president for the first time in late
1987 he went up to New Hampshire and
gave a speech at a Rotary Club I mean at
a restaurant and did it because he was
asked to by a guy in New Hampshire who
wanted him to run for president who was
going through some low-level formal
process to draft Donald Trump and I
don't know that he had ever really
thought seriously about running for
president at that time I don't think he
was even a even then and late night 87
but he knew he had a book to move and it
was coming out and so he went so he went
up and gave this speech and no doubt it
helped it helped move some product as
did in September of that year and ad he
put in the New York Times in the Boston
Globe and I think the post as well
criticizing American foreign policy and
saying basically a lot of the things he
said in this campaign all of this sort
of injected him into the political
bloodstream in late 1987 which then
alerted people to this forthcoming book
called the art of the deal he's kind of
done that over and over again right like
I mean he sort of flirted with running
and there was always something to pitch
at the time whether it's a book or a
show or something else Erica we deserved
comes out in 1989 when he's having his
dalliance with the Reform Party and now
of course crippled America there's
always a buck which isn't unique to
Donald Trump but he was doing it even
when he wasn't actually running for
did you know though when like six days
after Mitt Romney lost in the last
election he filed for the trademark make
America great again he was so convinced
then that he could have done better
now of course Romney is out there
talking and so convinced he could be
better than then Trump but on speaking
of people he praised in addition to
Jimmy Carter in the art in the in the
art of the deal you know even praised
Sylvester Stallone right in the art of
the deal for creating these characters
and so of what did he create rocky and
Rambo
thank you two of the all-time characters
yes I'm predicting that at the
Republican convention Sylvester Stallone
will make an appearance this I don't
know I just think these kind of people
he wants to bring some pizzazz you know
the showbiz the reality star aspect he
wants it to be more fun part of being a
celebrity is being in proximity to other
celebrities and the pictures in this
book as well as every other book that
has ever come out with his name on the
cover they are filled with pictures of
Donald Trump with other celebrities at
mar-a-lago at the the resort second home
or whatever number home in in Florida
that the Trump has heum in not in this
book but in in other books he talks
about everyone that he has down there
and you know Michael Jackson and Lisa
Marie Presley when they were together
they were there you know he talks about
having dinner with Sinatra
you know he he claims in this book he
doesn't like going to parties but he
clearly loves being in that party scene
and being being seen with with famous
people because it's that's what you know
that's his shtick right it's not just
he's not just a business exec cessful
business executive he's not not just a
politician he's he's all those things
he's everything and he's kind of been
this sort of exaggerated version of
every big thing in America for the last
several decades like in the 70s he was
you know partying in the New York clubs
you know in the 80s he was becoming you
know really rich in the 90s he had you
know financial struggles and you know
family you know everyone's having
affairs in the 90s right
mm suddenly he's he's you know reality
TV star you know and now he's like a
Twitter feed right he's like he's every
you know every obsession in America he
has captured it carlos Lozada recently
in The Washington Post you had a piece
recommending two novels or two books
that could be today it's sort of the
when you know this this thing that
you're seeing a lot is you know
journalists writing their Maricopa story
you know how I missed the rise of Trump
you know and it's always you know very
like on brand away that just really
proves that they were right in these
other ways but um but what you're seeing
too is people referring to - movies -
fiction - you know here's the movie that
foreshadowed the rise of Trump you know
and - that struck me were people
referring to Sinclair Lewis as it can't
happen here from the 1930s and Philip
Roth's applaud against america which
showed these kind of oddly charismatic
strong men coming to power in in in the
united states and of course it's it's
horrifying you know like it's it's a
very oppressive dictatorial state and so
i wanted to see what there was there in
in particularly in those two books i
also watched idiocracy this really weird
movie just like the people have been
citing but decided that wasn't worth
writing about and you know you see
glimmers of you know the the the appeal
there was a famous moment I came over
which primary after maybe it was Arizona
after Arizona you know he's on TV and
he's like I love the poorly educated you
know because because he had done so well
in that demographic and and you know in
those books the leaders that become
these kind of totalitarian figures you
know really had strong appeal among you
know we would now call low information
voters right and and so you see some
some parallels in the in the
combativeness with the press you know to
the point that there's this expectation
of fawning coverage you know otherwise
or something wrong these are sort of
very dystopian novels and they go much
further than
think Donald Trump would ever go but
there there are these kind of interludes
in history you know in in in Sinclair
Lewis what what happens is that you know
or excuse me in in the plot against
America Philip Roth's book you know
Charles Lindbergh comes to power and he
you know runs the country sort of
horribly for two years and then
disappears and then rebel comes back and
the u.s. enters the war and sort of like
everything history picks up as as it as
we know it which can't happen in real
life so I was looking for inspiration in
fiction and I think that there there's
certainly elements there that you you
recognize in Trump's personal style and
rhetoric and his appeal to the audience
that he seems to know so well perhaps
the most important thing I learned at
Wharton mr. Trump writes was not to be
overly impressed by academic credentials
it didn't take me long to realize that
there was nothing particularly awesome
or exceptional about my classmates
Michael Cruz with Politico let's go back
to where we started and playbook I think
it can be seen as such and it's it's of
a piece I mean there are lots of books
that he has written or co-written or
have been written for him that all added
up I think are the campaign playbook for
2016 for Donald Trump Monica Langley I
say definitively yes I think that it is
classic Donald Trump and I think that
elements of the deal are the elements of
his campaign